antoine clyro à moscou bonjour antoine
la propagation du court on a des russes
oblige le kremlin à prendre des mesures
sur son territoire oui tout à fait pour
la première fois le nombre de cas
confirmés a dépassé la barre des 1000
milles 36 pour être exact selon le
dernier décompte avec près de 200
nouveaux cas ces dernières 24 heures et
c'est toujours moscou qui on concentre
qui en concentrent la majorité avec 703
cas comptabilisés
le porte-parole du kremlin a d'ailleurs
fait savoir qu à l'employé de
l'administration présidentielle avaient
été contaminés le bilan humain officiel
quant à lui s'élève à 3 morts tandis
qu'au total 20 45 personnes ont guéri et
ont pu rentrer chez elle depuis le début
de la pandémie
je rappelle qu'à compter d'aujourd'hui
tous les vols internationaux depuis et
vers la russie sont suspendus ce les
avions qui ramène des citoyens russes
bloqués à l'étranger sont autorisés de
cette façon ces douze derniers jours pas
moins de cinquante trois mille personnes
ont pu être rapatriés et à la suite de
l'adresse de vladimir poutine de ce
mercredi
tous les cafés et restaurants ferment
leurs portes dès demain samedi les
mesures les plus restrictives jusque-là
reposé uniquement à moscou vont
également être étendue je vous propose
d'écouter sur ce sujet le premier
ministre russe roussneft chto ce que
vous savez que la semaine prochaine a
été déclarée semaines de congés par le
président a cédé garges est-il
nécessaire d'étendre à toutes les
régions de notre pays
les mesures restrictives déjà prise à
moscou et dans la région de moscou
il s'agit tout d'abord du secteur des
loisirs et des divertissements
ces décisions sont évidemment dur et je
voudrais m'adresser à tous les citoyens
de notre pays
prenez au sérieux et agissez de manière
responsable du site estime celui qui est
pour limiter les déplacements à
l'intérieur du territoire russe le
gouvernement suspend les réservations et
l'hébergement dans les centres de
loisirs les centres de santé
et autres sanatorium jusqu'au 1er juin
2001 avec toutes ces mesures successives
on se rapproche donc dans les faits de
plus en plus au scénario de confinement
actuellement vigueur en france
merci beaucoup antoine clairon en direct
de vos scoops on doit faire un point sur
la situation en russie